glitz glamour and six dollar iced  coffees  welcome to beautiful los angeles  california the entertainment capital of  the world  and home to the tiger belly seeing  competition we've received over 10  million submissions across 54 states  and nine different continents join us as  we embark on a journey  to find out which sleeper will sing the  tiger belly outro song  after carefully reviewing submissions  for months our submission committee  has chosen the top finalists at this  audition stage  of the competition your mentors bobby  and koloko  will choose their favorite songs and  those will move on throughout the  competition  so guys let's get started  [Applause]  [Music]